So what happened to your startup?
Well, I took a break cause, uh, that's some other priorities going on. Yeah.
I want to work on personal development, you know, building relationship,
networking, and also just overall learning more.
And while I was doing that, uh,
had to look over to my old hard drives because I want to find some important
documents and some important notes.
And I found something pretty interesting.
And when I clicked into it, you know, I just opened up the wallet and I'll,
and there it is. And then it hit me. I remembered, you know,
I used to mind Bitcoins. It was probably like five, five or six years ago.
I remember trying to get enough so that I could buy a pizza slice,
but I just couldn't get enough. I mean, I think he had,
I think he needed like 10,000 Bitcoins to get a slice of pizza, but yeah.
Only had like a hundred something, but I'm going to check the price.
And I was like, well, yeah. And I said to myself, my God,
what do I do with all that money? It's crazy. All of the things I can buy,
but then I remembered I live in Silicon Valley. All I can afford a new house.
Yeah. I guess I'm a homeowner now, but I mean,
I ran out of money, so I have to start making money again. But yeah.
So that's why I'm back.
[Inaudible] the pitch.
One of the most important aspect of your startup,
no matter how great your ideas,
if you can't convey it and you don't have any capital,
then your startup is useless.
And if you can inspire people and you don't have a team already working for you,
then your startup is a useless. But wait,
what if I can make a product that doesn't require much capital and I don't need
a team, I could do it by myself. Well, I mean,
if you can't convey your idea to customers,
then you're not going to have any customers.
And if you don't have any customers, then your startup is useless.
Every interaction relating to your startup,
you will somehow require to pitch it.
Now that is why it is essential to perfect.
Your pitch easier said than done.
Here are the seven questions that you should answer as clearly as possible.
With these in mind,
you'll be able to do ten second pitches to a five minute presentation with demo.
Number one, what do you do? Be as clear as possible. No fluff,
no to test it. The email tests write two sentences,
describing your startup in an email,
send it to a competent friend and ask them to re-explain to you with his own
words. If they can do that, then you're golden. Number two.
How big is the market? Investors care about ROI.
If there's no market for a product, then their investment isn't worth it.
Don't make your target market too wide or too narrow. Make it correct.
You're only wasting people's time. If you're making up numbers, number three,
what's your progress.
They want to make sure you guys are actually doing something.
What is possible in a given timeframe? What can you do?
Number four. What's your unique insight or in some sense,
what's your competitive advantage?
How are you different than the startup next door?
What makes you more likely to succeed in your market? Number five,
what's your business model? How are we going to make money?
Are you the grow fast? Think about money later kind of company,
or would you be making money right away?
It's always better to have a plan of attack when it comes to monetization.
Number six, who's on your team. What are your credentials? Who's technical.
Who's not, who's doing what is everyone useful? Are you as lean as possible?
Number seven, what do you want?
This can be capital convincing someone to work for you,
or simply to tell your mom that you're actually doing something and that you're
not wasting her life savings on your pet projects.
And that this time it's gonna blow up.
For sure.
Once you have these answered now compress it into 30 seconds. Here's my,
My surf is called not fine.com platform to create and share 6.1 second,
looping videos. We have a market size of at least 200 million.
Given the fact that a similar product has just left this market.
I made no progress. I understand the market, both consumer and producer.
I've been working in the publishing industry for over five months,
which makes me an expert in social media and media publishing.
You can monetize through advertisement, branded content and presets posts.
I am currently the only one on my team and I want you to join my startup.
Hmm.
[Inaudible] but.
What's your background? Oh, just worked on a couple of startups.
Um, mostly just like fitness related startups.
Uh he's my best friend's ex was the breakup like
pretty bad.
I mean, I'm sure John was still cries over it.
Now you're all here because you're the best engineers.
Now I need something from you guys.
And today I'm going to talk about my startup and here's my presentation,
velocity, compassion,
spirituality. What do all these things have in common?
I present to you.
Not vine.com
a platform to share 6.1 second long looping videos.
Oh, you know, I love him, man. You know, vine was w bine was awesome,
but not vine. It's going to be bad. It's going to be way better.
Excited. Uh, I don't know.
Pretty dumb to be honest.
Do they started by using utterly ridiculous.
I created four startups by the time I was 18.
I can build that back end infrastructure during an episode of Battlestar
Galactica.
Well, I'm just a Bubba delivery guy, but you know, when I saw the slides,
I thought it was pretty cool.
Do you want me to say it's like a pretty cool seat?
Well, how to dream, that's going to be like really, really successful.
And then after that I had another dream about taco bell and Wendy's creating
like a burrito burger. So all in all, I'm really excited about it.
Would you work for that startup? Oh dude. No.
And what else? It's also eight mobile now.
Oh, I think it's great.
I love vine and always been checking those videos and being on it. Yeah.
I think it's awesome that they're bringing it back.
You do realize it's not vine. Right? Right.
What opportunities research shows that there was a similar product.
That reached 200 million active users.
On December, 2015.
But that product is no longer in the market and left a need. Unsatisfying.
That is where we come in.
This thing is a complete and utter scam. It's not like Bitcoin,
which is legitimate. It's like dumb like queen or a theory of,
I would never pay it launch roadmaps though.
Oh yeah. He likes, uh, he's one of my followers he's followed me on Instagram,
Twitter, Snapchat.
And then one day he just like messaged me and yeah, we started talking. Um,
yeah, I think his handle is, uh,
at Joma OPA that's J O M a
O P P.
And our main competitive advantage. Me.
What do you think about gentleman as the CEO?
Oh yeah. He's a really great friend. Jamal is a really bad boyfriend.
There was this one time when he forgot Christina's birthday,
because he was so immersed in watching vine videos.
Doing work in research.
Explain this for you, commonplace people. If this was star Trek,
the next generation, I would be commander data because I'm a genius.
He would be Lieutenant ward because he's just running around and making stupid
decisions all the time.
I bet Joma had to study off stack overflow to make it through a Microsoft
interview. I would never work for the startup in a million years,
not even a million light years. And that's not even a time. It's a distance.
Now what's their business model. Now we have a lot of sources of revenue.
We got advertisement 70%.
Right. Do you think you would work for them? Oh yeah. Sure. Man.
I'm just chilling right now, but I'll definitely work for them.
Do you have a job right now? You know, I'm in between jobs,
you know, just in that in-between, uh,
my mom always says, I'm an entrepreneur.
What's your criminal record
next step.
So what we need to do next, we need to create the iOS app.
We need to make the backend a lot stronger and we need to innovate.
Don was a pretty good guy. He gets, Bubba was 100%.
Sweetness, just like his heart, Joe mutt drinks,
his Boba with 100% sweetness.
To manage all the marketing platforms. Any questions? Yeah.
So what kind of people are looking for? Yeah, so I'm looking for like, uh,
flexible engineers and our engineers are pretty much full stack backend front
end. If you're not afraid of touching all of these pieces of code, then. Yeah.
You're definitely good for jobs. If you can do that.
There you go do with $420 and 69 cents.
Yeah. That's a good question. I mean, I'll definitely invest in not bind.com.
I mean, we need as much capital as we can, so yeah,
definitely invested any more questions.
Okay. Turn to camera. Hey, do you mind?
Can you stop interrupting? All right. Any more questions?
What's your tech stack? Well, um, what you, you know, like the, the,
the mean stack. Yeah. I mean, we could do the nice stack too. I mean, like it's,
it's pretty flexible right now. Yeah. So I mean, nice stack means that,
you know, it's all good. It depends on what you want, you know,
do you even code
of course, come on. I mean, have a CS degree.
First of all, the name not fine. She's not going to work.
And I don't know. I just wasn't listening honestly.
Do you think they liked your pitch? Of course not. I mean, I'm not stupid.
I know what they're saying, but that's the thing not fine.
It's just the marking scheme for something bigger.
[inaudible] happy new years, everybody let's. Uh, now if you enjoyed this video,
don't forget to click the subscribe button and also turn on post notifications,
because that will tell you when the next episode of startup will come out and a
little update.
I have a Patrion page now you don't have to be a patrolling thing,
but I'm just going to post all the behind the scenes,
all the fun stuff that I didn't get to put in the actual episode,
I'll put it in there so you guys can check it out and follow me on Instagram at
Joe [inaudible] and Twitter at Joe MOPA. You know,
so I can talk to you guys and also thank you guys so much.
I've now reached a thousand subscribers and as a thank you,
I am going to do a giveaway, more details on that later. See ya.